The moon is a giant rock.
The lights up our night and can even change colors.
So what would it be?
Do without it?
What do we all need?
Night Vision Goggles.
How would it affect the ocean tides are seasons or our sleep cycles or would the
consequences be far more dramatic?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we suddenly had no moon as the closest celestial
body to our planet.
The moon exerts a gravitational pull that governs much of what happens here on
earth.
Take the sea,
for example,
if you like surfing,
you can thank the moon.
When the moon's gravitational pull tugs on our spinning earth,
the oceans respond,
giving us high tides and some parts of the world and low tides elsewhere.
And while the wind gives the waves,
their energy,
tides define their shape,
the moon's gravitational attraction also keeps us at a stable 23.5 degree tilt
relative to the sun giving us four seasons and a livable climate.
But what if that livable climate were to suddenly become unlivable with the moon
gone?
It's stabilizing effect on the earth's rotation would go with it.
One,
the good news first,
the weekend just got a whole lot closer.
If the moon suddenly disappeared,
a day on earth would only be six to eight hours long.
Over millions of years shifting tides and their pressure on the earth's
continents have slowed our planet's rotation giving us 24 hour days,
but without the moon strong gravitational influence,
the world would spend three to four times faster than it does now.
Here comes the bad news.
Rotating at that speed,
we would experience winds up to 480 kilometers per hour.
Birds and insects would have no chance of survival.
The luckiest land based organisms would either be deeply rooted plants or very
short,
very stout animals.
Most of our marine life would be wiped out since sea creatures that rely on
ocean currents for survival would lose the privilege of the oceans.
Pull currents helps circulate vital nutrients from the ocean floor to the
surface while dragging oxygen rich surface water deep into the sea.
We'd still have tides,
but now they'd be governed by the sun and from a distance of 93 million miles
away,
they'd only be one third is powerful.
And with the moon,
suddenly out of the way,
the oceans would rip towards the sun causing catastrophic waves,
killing thousands and submerging coastlines.
At this point,
we'd have to adjust to new ocean currents,
which circulating at a slower rate would be heating up equatorial waters while
turning polar waters frigid.
These extreme differences would produce a similar effect on land as well.
Since ocean temperatures influenced their regional climates,
along with the sun,
Mars,
and other nearby planets could also claim a share of gravitational influence
over our planet,
pulling on earth in different directions and causing it to tilt.
With increased volatility,
Earth's axial plane would vary some 10 degrees causing dramatic shifts in
seasons and rendering our climate uninhabitable.
Most crops would die with drastic temperature changes.
We'd experienced the worst ice ages,
known demand as huge glaciers from the north and South Poles would encroach upon
the earth covering everything except perhaps a small band across the equator.
So while full moons may attract werewolves,
that's still better than an alternative world where the moon doesn't exist.
The next time you look up at the sky,
be glad it's there.
Sleep soundly tonight.
Surf's up in the morning.